We're picking up a 12-day shell left off around the little duck, and again we're going
to where things went nominal, as per the checklist we're going to get the little surface
checklist you have for them.
Okay, we're going to say so.
We did not do the P-22 and everything else just went as advertised on a limb she came
up to power it up beautifully, okay the left off was again when we went normal we got
all the obviously all our pyros and we lost no change over parker valves or anything.
The only thing that I would like to mention, let the on-peak pick it up here is very soon
after liftoff.
We had a pair of loss of calm, a lot of noise, and he has been.
It turned out that we worked down monkey, but it was something wrong with the uplink.
So the CDR watched the most of the guidance and we'd call out in a blind altudes and
goes and what have you as we've pitched over and pressed on up but for about the first two
or three minutes I think the Lunar Module Pollard had to concern self of trying to get
a combat.
Yeah, I meant again it was when I was apparently a gutter or a goldstone, dropped the uplink
and when they were getting back I was switching on these and for a while there was just
completely out of phase and what they were trying to have a continuous dynamic.
It was a very in-opportun time I might say too because it happened just right after
I think that's something that goes into being able to clarify because we certainly can't
give you the details.
It was essentially no calm and all the antennas.
We got into a, they pre-pours on a trajectory, we flew into a trajectory that appeared
to be nominal.
The Ag showed us slide out a plane, I believe, and as a result our tweak had nine-foot
per second, it was minus four, minus nine and plus one, we burned out X, Z, Y, net order
and it looked like the Ag's out of plane, in the case it was good, about 70 per second
rule over 70.
It looked like we might have had a somewhat a g-sensitive drift in our Y accelerometer
and the pangs but the tweak as it turned out was an excellent tweak because our rendezvous
resulted in just as nominal rendezvous in a nominal trajectory and profile as I guess
I've ever been involved with.
The drift in X accelerometer did not bother us anywhere else in the tracking or in the
rendezvous at all, rendezvous navigation was followed the checklist.
We got right off the farm very well, we had auto updates into the Ag's.
The only thing I might mention here is when it came to making a TPI burn, we, the residuals
s in the TPI burn were greater than what I had expected them and we did not record it
because I wanted to get them, I wanted to get them knelled out just as soon as possible
but they were, and I don't know the tents but they were minus seven in X and they were
four and four and I'm not sure whether they were plus or minus in the Y and Z but they
were the point I'm making is they were larger than I had expected them were minus seven
and four point something in the four point something.
We reduced those to a less than two tenths of a foot per second and from there on continued
to plot right through the mid courses right up the pike on a nominal trajectory.
These after that first, they'll lash up again in common about that.
Common was good, a couple of comments about the eggs.
After about five or ten minutes, early in, insertion, I always checked the accelerometer
for the after insertion and they looked really, really good and checked about five or ten
less later and I can't remember exactly.
I looked and I had accumulated a foot or two per foot and a half, which would be for
a second in X.
So I was a gene in one three and I did a gyrocal and after that there was no significant
accumulation in X under the world.
I did that without talking to the ground but I thought I had an understanding that
it was something that you could do.
Okay, the, another installation on the TPI Solutions, the eggs, had essentially a, with
two or three feet per second, a good TPI solution after six marks.
The insertion solution was not very good.
It was off by a number of feet per second in X and even more in Z.
This was your first 2017 marks and this was the funding chain.
The Ping's, every cycle in Ping's final word, for a couple of feet per second in
the launch and X, and a Ping's recycle head, I don't remember exactly because for 15 marks
in the kind.
So I had 17, 17, 17, 17.
And there's more data than they occurred with about various eggs, certain times marks
with the egg solution.
Okay, mid-course solutions, first mid-course agreed effectively, all systems except eggs
out of plane was a little bit high and the decision was made to burn the onboard Ping
solution out of the lamp, which was minus 1.2 plus 0.4 and plus 0.3.
We continued to track right up the pike, mid-course 2 came up and we again compared all
the solutions.
The eggs out of plane was still a little bit high and in actually the opposite direction
from the things.
We had a slight variation in the CSM solution in Z, I don't know why, it came up with
plus 5.4 feet per second in Z.
So we really didn't get a very good correlation between the CSM and the lamb on the second
mid-course, but the pings was still performing, the radar was still performing and based upon
our trajectory plot and based upon our following the nominal national line of site rates,
we decided to burn the pings onboard Ping solution in the lamp and it was minus 0.4 minus
0.7 and minus 1.6 and from there on I would just continue to follow the inertial line
of site angles and very little tweaking in either in Y or Z and we just sort of floated
right through the breaking gates at one mile and we put about 6 or 7 feet per second off
to hit 30.
We met all the gates as prescribed and just came very moving very slowly into the final
station keeping, went into a formation flight around the CSM, got a good inspection of the
spacecraft and the Sim Bay, the report of which is in a transcript, everything looked good to us.
We eventually went over to the command module, over to the docking attitude, allowing
to just took his position, his docking attitude, did his pitch in Yometer over and gave
the station keeping control to the command module, the pitching Yometer over and stood by for
for docking.
Okay, yes, remember I was about it proceeding on with the docking.
I think one of the more noticeable differences between this docking and the docking with the
S-4B is the fact that the S-M stage did bands a lot more than the S-4B did.
S-4B is studies a rock that you could tell, you just watch the lamb did that because
he would change attitude and then you'd try to follow it and looking on the first attempt
coming in, I must have less than a tenth of a foot per second, just barely closing on it.
So I was just taking a nice and easy, made contact and did not get captured.
Okay, soon as it didn't get captured, obviously you could close them too slow, but back
off a couple of three feet, I guess, so I'm not going to have to renew all the rates and
initiate it to close and rate and make it got captured.
As soon as we hit the captured, both vehicles went to a C-M-C-3 and you look around and
check the barber poles and whatever, it looked back out and there I had some rates in
the C-S-M, but I'm sure now that the lamb had a race also, you must have had.
Right, so we did one as soon as we went free, since his capture, the lamb went free and
the C-S-M trying to know the rates ended up pertivating the lamb and giving us rates.
So we finally gave up on that mode, had the lamb go to attitude hole and then once you go
to attitude hole, then the C-S-M can know the rates and we'll line up and attempt at the
hard docking, no problem, probably trapped, came back this time, it didn't sound like
it was as much of a ripple fire, it was more of a... and it was a quicker docking, I
put that hard docking, it was a previous time.
Again, we're taking it.
Okay, I want to say some about visual sightings during the round of the... I was able
to, from the lamb, I was able to see the command module in, when it was sunlit at somewhere
around a hundred miles and definitely defined that that was a command module.
After the command module, one of the darkness, I could not pick up his tracking light until
we were well within about 40 miles.
I like this transcript, it got more an accurate time, but could not pick up the docking
light, the rendezvous light, rather from the command module to what was in 40 miles
and then just a very, initially very dim faint flash.
I was able to verify on board that the lamb tracking light was working and I finally figured
out how it was reflecting off the underside of the EVA hand rail on the left, forward side
of the lamb.
So I could see the lamb tracking light flashing and also whenever there were some particles
we took with us that stayed with the spacecraft and you could see the sequential flash
off of those particles, there was a result of our lamb tracking light.
Okay, this is the command module part of the information section in 11.0 about the visibility
of the module through the optic.
I got down here.
Anything else to add about that?
I would be in television.
I'm retired from the lamb.
We'll just have to wait and see how it turned out.
I took a lot of footage.
In fact, as we put it on the Async mag, we put it on the other mag, we had a part of the
mag.
So we had to include the same day, right or wrong, we did have a hospital on board, so we
had a lot of hospital photography, the rendezvous, and some of the surface stuff in the
process.
Okay, post-docking chair, we're going to 13.0 lunar module jettison through TEI, post-docking
check and pressurization.
Well, first of all, I guess you said you had every last made this time, right?
Every last worked.
Well, 12-docking module is worked.
Okay.
That sounds like there's something to do with the mass and we ought to be going along.
The general comment I want to make about the post-docking operations is at the, throughout
the rendezvous, the both pilots in the lamb kept their helmets on for dust, keep the dust
off primarily.
The commander took off his gloves a little bit, almost immediately after insertion,
included the entire round of it that way, he took yourself some time later.
I can't mind on after we've done a lot of times for our camera, but I kept your gloves
on too.
You can hold that.
Oh, okay.
After insertion, I did most of my pre-insertion work with the gloves off because I didn't
want to take the time, I want to get that initial air solution and I could get that fairly
rapidly with the gloves and I didn't take the gloves off until maybe 10 or 15 minutes after
insertion.
But I kept the helmet on all the way through most of the transfer, just to avoid reading
the dust that I've had the air station, the sign of the air station on the surface.
And the commander kept the helmet on throughout the rendezvous and docking that took my
gloves off after insertion and left them off now.
Now, we started, we started getting prepared, since we were a hard dog, the commander took
off his helmet and as I looked back at that because of the dust debris in the lambs
spacecraft, I'm sorry I did it.
I could have left the helmet on and I would have had a lot less, not troublesome, but it
was just eye-in-mouth type of air station, you knew you were in a very heavily infiltrated
atmosphere in the lambs because of the lunar dust, although I don't know how much lunar
dust previous flights had, but I think we saved a great deal of grief by taping up, by
sweeping all the dust we could find on the floor into the holes and putting our tape covers
over those holes, I think that had to help a great deal because there was an awful lot of dust
on the floor that we didn't see.
So I had to, commander had his helmets and goes off, off throughout the entire transfers.
Basically the way we handle a transfer was the way we planned, I think the lambs pilot
did most of the preparation of the gear in the lambs and in the commander's state, in
the tunnel, and the passenger's on and the inventory was going on on a command module
side, and on the lambs side both, we vacuumed each other's suits the best we could
and everything else that got supposedly transferred on bagged or uncovered.
This is young things, five of the C&P's comments to the contrary, I think we got things
remarkably clean and it wasn't an awful lot of dirt in the command module coming back.
Really what's going on?
That's true.
I didn't watch that.
I trust he may have thought it was dirty, but I was surprised we were able to keep the
level of the Department of Trust and Contamination on command module down.
That atmosphere that the commander was referring to in a lambs after took this helmet
off, I could go halfway through the tunnel and stick my head up into the command module
and it was totally refreshed, unpolluted atmosphere up there that never did get polluted.
I think having a vacuum cleaner runny in the lambs had a lot to do with keeping the flow
in the environment.
And so we're out to here, we never did vacuum in the command module because this was
a messenger, it was a messenger, it was a messenger, it was a messenger, and as the
suits were noticeably clean by the vacuum cleaner, you could tell you were pulling stuff
off of them all the way, you're still dirty and every other time we handled it, we got
our hands dirty, but I think most of the pre-desk was taken care of.
We effectively stayed on a transfer list, I said effectively throughout the transfer,
however, some things got transferred out of order, and got temporarily stowed in the command
module, but we effectively used the transfer list as a, not as a cookbook, follow recipe
type of thing, but as an inventory list.
And we had it several times from both hands and found out that we were satisfied we had
everything transferred, and then pressed on with the lambs closed up.
lambs closed up, went down, we got back into the, into the lambs, or into the command
module, and the commander closed up, the, the enemy closed up the lambs, and for convenience
the commander effectively went back and closed up the lambs hatch, put in the command
module hatch, because of the slow tunnel vent, there's a long duration of tunnel vent,
the commander stayed in the tunnel, the LNP, and his seat in the CMP, and let's see,
we suited up and got prepared for our, for our integrity check, as soon as the, as soon
as the line tunnel vent was complete, and we were satisfied with integrity of the hatch,
we went into the, to the, suit integrity checks, you know, this is the CMP, let me make
another comment on the tunnel vent time, I bet it must take, and I'm not sure if this is correct,
but I bet at least three or four times longer than the simulator is for the tunnel vent move.
And I think that's going to be able to pull the skylab, because of the new talking,
uh, they're going to have to vent before they have to dock, they're quite a, it took part of one.
But kind of close, I was easy, we had no, no, a joke, no probe, which were still, uh, in the, uh,
uh, lamp for, uh, lamp jet, going through the rest of these, uh, my triggers, uh, under the
branch of some fruit tea, I would just follow the checklist and did all seem to happen just as
after-touched. Well, we got a little bit intrigued with the, uh, the lung
jones, you know, this time it was, it was great, and it just sailed out there nice and pretty,
and we got a lot of good pictures, uh, uh, where we should have been maneuvering, and we ended
up, uh, getting into P-41 after the, for the sub burn, uh, a little bit of light, but that's
no problem, either, because we just run the resettles from P-41 on the hand, got a good
sub burn.
I want to make a comment that I think cleaning control, uh, in a command module, uh, was
excellent, considering all the dust and all the dirt, uh, that just seemed to adhere to
everything in a lamp, and we got back in a command module with the exception of these suits,
and with the exception of the LNP and the CDR, uh, everything, uh, was clean, uh, and
that's, for the most part, is because everything was bad before we brought it over, bag
and zipped, and we never did open anything, uh, once we got it zipped up, so the command
module stayed, and I think that suit fan filter is probably going to be very, very clean
in the state, exceptionally clean throughout the remainder of the slides.
I mean, uh, in the bagging, kind of the deep and damnation bags, I made a special effort
to ask for, uh, request, uh, create a launch to, uh, pull those differences tight as I
put, and they should be pretty tight, see.
Okay, uh, orbital navigation high gain, why don't I just pick that up?
Okay, I've already, uh, from, except the TEI, I have no, uh, no comments.
I gained, uh, always worked good on these in this band were good, uh, photography, uh,
when as advertised, we have a lot of, uh, of, uh, targets of opportunity.
Uh, symbi operations, uh, have been mentioned before.
Let me just make one gross comment about the way we handle it as a three-man crew at
symbi operations, which after, uh, did we?
Yeah.
Okay.
It's covered.
I don't know.
Okay.
I think I did say so.
Yeah.
Let me do it.
Okay.
The TEI updates.
No.
Flexing to start checks, uh, we're good for TEI.
I think commander's master alignment every one of them all through the field.
Which made me feel good.
But you kept trying to get it.
I made sure.
I made sure I got it.
I was last few hours ago to change any mode of operation.
I'll tell you that last one, uh, well, we're entry was last one.
I made sure I got it on TEI.
Just make you guys feel at home.
I figured you took, I didn't do it right if I didn't get the master on.
The TEI, a hat g here, whatever we were pulling there, uh, was, uh, seemed like more than
that.
It's quite nice.
I sure did.
It seemed like it was really pushing it back in the seat.
Yeah.
Around my goals, I think started out holding our heads up and eventually relaxed and back
on the, on the couch.
I guess we must have had the spacecraft pretty well stowed or tied down because, uh, as
the CFP and LNP and as I recall, those kind of burns back on Apollo 10, lots of things
start moving through the spacecraft and find their due, uh, on the, uh, on the aft, uh,
end of the spacecraft because of the G-load and much to my surprise.
All we had was initial thought as we moved away from the station and we didn't have any
gear coming from anywhere flying through the spacecraft.
Yeah.
So we had cleaned it up pretty well.
I found, I got a, uh, caught up white tag, wet white tag, wet, wet, wet, wet.
But other than, there may be one or two of those things, uh, in looking back, uh, I would
have expected more gear to come from somewhere, but, uh, we prepared for those birds pretty
well.
Well, that reminds, brings up another point that reminds me of, uh, is it, there is always
water condensing on ECU, uh, you know, the pipes and whatever you're back in there when you
get back to cleaning the suit, turn the return belt.
And, uh, when we put our suits on for the EVA, the next day, your, your suits were
noticeably wet.
And, uh, also, when I pulled the PGA bag up, it was damp down underneath the PGA bag.
So I think, uh, as a normal procedure, we should have, uh, either after the burn, probably
before the burn, make sure we wipe it to water and the LED, somehow, and be there.
I wasn't really aware of our suits for damp work, but I was not aware.
I could look down here and I could not find any real water down in the down there.
But just done ECU.
Yes.
Yeah.
I just assumed that's where all I came from.
But, uh, it was all over, it's, it's, it's not a pole of water, like you say, it's just
damp and almost as if it was colder down than the LED and water was convincing on all, all
over the suits.
It wasn't as if they were in a program.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think that covers, uh, right on through, uh, T. Yeah.
Let's see.
Yeah.
The one thing I want to mention on T.E.I. is that, uh, again, the simulator is set up such
as a, uh, in the role of dead band, because over the one side of the role of that band,
just kind of stays there and, uh, trying to T.E.I. burn, uh, it was bouncing back and forth
from one side of the, uh, to dead band, throw to the other side of the dead band.
And when it's bouncing back and forth, the role rate is up around, uh, all forecasts, uh,
four times a degree for a second, arguing back and forth across the role of dead band.
Okay.
14.0 chance of a coast and a thing that I just realized we've neglected to say anywhere
about systems, uh, like I mentioned, chlorination at this point.
Uh, I think without fail, do you have a target?
No.
I think without fail, almost every chlorination.
Leaked.
Uh, sometimes larger quantities of water, other times just small quantities of water.
Can I tell you where it leads?
Water or corn?
Well, it's common.
It's pouring in your corn, ain't it?
And, uh, in buffer or water when you withdrew the buffer sample here.
But where it leaked was appeared to me to leak within the ampule itself around the bag
because it was the pouring, the cylindrical chlorine dispenser that was continually wet.
It was not the, uh, it was not where the, uh, dispenser fit into the needle or where the, uh, needle adapter
fit into the spacecraft.
It was within the barrel chlorine dispenser itself.
And, uh, we continually, chlorination was, uh, was a, uh, a case of, uh, of always cleaning
your hands with chlorine because you always had it available down there within that dispenser.
And in some cases, you had larger quantities of water that had to be wiped up with, uh, with a tissue.
That played us throughout the whole mission.
It turned out not to be a serious problem because we learned how to handle it.
But, uh, that was one system anomaly that never had really been brought out.
Okay, but let's see, uh, let's see, I mean, I forgot that a little bit.
And, uh, two cases are almost positive that when you put the thing on the bayonet setting and crank it on there.
It did not puncture the ampule itself.
And the reason I can, I believe that's correct is that, uh, when you start to, to crank the, uh, outside of the cassette,
down there's, to press the chlorine into the, into the water system.
It was very hard to turn.
And if you, if you tried to force it, you could force it on down there and I'm sure that's a good way to,
to break an answer or something.
And if you take it, I just, uh, in two cases,
took the bayonet setting loose again and put it back on there and, and in both cases,
uh, then you just try to squeeze the, uh, chlorine out of the ampule into the system.
And it would turn easier, but it's still hard to, it's probably hard to also get all the hard to think down.
But, uh, we did not, you know, we got the chlorination done.
We didn't miss any injections of chlorine.
And we didn't miss, uh, we didn't miss any, uh, the buffer samples.
Uh, so I guess we got the job done.
It was just a little bit messy.
And chlorine was evident in because, uh, the CDR eventually filled all the other skin off his right hand.
And I'm convinced it was due to the chlorine and had nothing to do with the EVA.
Oh, you lost a little, a little question, a little skin.
Transurous goals, systems navigation.
Let's press on and see what we can say about that.
Okay, uh, let me see how much transurous goes we're going to do.
Let's get, yeah, let's go through up to the CSMEBA anyway.
Okay, okay, transurous, the first thing I want to mention is passive,
thermal control was at what I would call unusual attitudes,
because of the UVN IR requirements.
Now these unusual attitudes did two things.
They, uh, they put us, uh, they required us to remen over the spacecraft several
times and exit enter and exit PTC several several times,
which in itself was not a problem.
Just, uh, additional, uh, coordination, uh, coincidentally,
most of these, uh, particular PTC attitudes were within 30 certainly forty-five
degrees of gimbalock, most of the time.
So we're looking at the red apple, good portion of the trip home, uh,
but they also, uh, some of those attitudes where you actually were not in,
we were in attitudes and or PTC at these relatively unusual positions.
Uh, change the, uh, the equilibrium heat load on a spacecraft.
You could see it in, uh, in RCS, uh, quad temperatures,
where I could, you could see it in helium package temperatures.
And most notably, you could see it on the change in, uh, condensation
from the tunnel hatch to the, uh, forward hatch,
the tunnel hatch eventually from most of the way home ended up to be very dry.
Uh, and the, uh, about the second day out on the way home,
the, uh, the, uh, four or the, uh,
center hatch, uh, got soaking wet to the point that, uh,
even took a dry rag and wiped off some of the, uh,
latch components and some of the, uh, gearbox components,
like strongly not that it did any good,
but there was just that much water on it.
And I think this is all due to the PTC attitudes required for the,
uh, some of the experiments on the way home.
I was colder in the spacecraft too.
Oh, yes, it was colder.
Not as cold as the commander thought it was.
That's cool.
Cool enough to warm up on the commander's orders.
And I just mentioned we wanted to put the ground suggestion of extra,
uh, we're going to manual on 10, 10, 10.
I think we discussed that.
We're on all your, uh, all your, uh, your rough smat changes, uh,
your, uh, talking and platform torque is all those, uh,
one very well.
I thought that went great.
Well, everyone.
The, uh, uh, and all the way back home as it was just changing attitudes,
changing attitudes, changing attitudes with exception of the EVA day,
which we'll cover here shortly.
Yes, um, EVA.
Okay, an EVA prep.
I think the only amount that we came across as the CMPs, uh,
well, let's see, an EVA prep, but really didn't have any.
You didn't know anything at that point.
I mean, I was going to say, I'm a CMPs, uh, proper.
But the EVA prep went, uh, right down the line,
essentially, as well, uh, well, way down within the, uh,
experienced checklist and we checked things off as we went and, uh,
stayed pretty much on the timeline.
We started about a half hour, uh, state of Africa.
We, uh, we, uh, we started, we were half hour early throughout the whole thing
in.
We lost that half hour in open heads,
just about it can turn to me on exactly on time.
I can't remember a small little,
it was a concentration of healthcare.
Complicated your change.
But we lost that half hour.
We're doing a concrete change on a tone.
Uh, Ron, I'd like to add that, uh, host EVA.
That, uh, I think one thing that helped us, uh,
immensely on what ended up with me.
I think it was very fine, uh,
and free storage was that we sort of, uh,
backed off after the EVA and, uh,
and, uh,
took a long, good long list of the long range storage as well as the
full TVA storage and really effectively started housekeeping,
clean up the cabin and effectively stowing some of the articles that
were not going to be used any further in the mission for entry.
At that time, at that time, every storage really started with the
post EVA timeframe period.
And I think that really helped us out in the long range.
Okay.
I think, uh, we should mention how we got out of the suit.
I think for me, that was pretty important, uh,
way to get things done.
And the only change,
the only change to the prep and or post was the order in which we
docked in Don suits because it was very evident that there were certain
convenient ways because of the way the students were stowed.
And, uh,
the way people fit into the, uh, checklist that we, uh,
when we down the suits that come under,
got Don, you can't, you got him first and I didn't.
Then the LNP and the NSC MP got Don last and it worked out very
fine and we're close to CMP had less work to do in his suit,
which also aided him in the long range.
Well, we dropped.
I worked with the LNP.
Yeah, because that was definitely first.
Okay, then you've done the CDR and then the CMP and that
wasn't exactly what it was called for.
But that's what it worked out.
And we stowed our suits any else shape bag prior to putting the
center couch back in,
which was, uh, another good decision, I believe, uh,
it helped me.
Let's get the suit stowed back in and I'll show it back.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Let's go on down, uh, cabin depress.
Uh, no problems, normal, uh, depress hatch opening.
Uh,
even though the hatch was completely, uh,
or the cabin was completely depressed and we're reading zero pressure on
a thing as soon as I opened the hatch.
There was enough residual pressure or something inside the spacecraft
that it actually tended to pull the hatch on a bus.
You're out of my hand is bleeding into the cabin all the time.
She never truly gets zero.
That's right.
You never truly get zero on the thing, but the jump valve was still open.
And, uh, if I had not been hanging on to the hatch, it would blow it all
over.
Or on to give you an idea on that's, that's exact.
That's not unexpected because it's exactly what we had on the lunar surface.
We completely, completely dumped the lamp and I'd still have to break
that hatch loose and hold it open about six or eight inches until
things just entered.
And then I could leave go of the hatch and open it all the way.
If I didn't, it was flying back closed.
Oh, yeah, different type of stuff.
So it was basically the same thing.
You got to open it up and really let things get down to zero.
Okay, well, when I opened the hatch and all of the, uh, excuse me, all the, uh,
little ice crystals and everything started flowing out, uh,
a pandemic floating by something else went floating by.
Wouldn't quite sure what it was.
But, uh, as well as a little part of the particles and pieces
start coming out through the hatch.
But I sure didn't see, I look specifically for the system.
I, uh, I didn't see any scissors go out that hatch.
I had to say another one by my watch.
I didn't let them went by me.
Ron, I'd like to say that they went out there, the hatch,
but I sure didn't see them go.
Right.
You didn't go by.
I caught the one thing.
I went start to go by me and put it in your pocket.
You got it.
Okay.
The, uh, once the, uh, all particles and, and, uh,
Chuck was out of the way, then he just pushed the hatch open.
We had disconnected the, uh, counterbalance, uh, uh,
with the beat tool be there.
So that, uh, we locked the hatch in the open position.
So I just shoved it open.
And it went beyond the, uh, center position and, uh,
locked in the open position with no problems.
He dressed, uh, had a tendency.
I guess, uh, just like, uh, any other thing.
It seems like you want to float up.
And I had a tendency to float up against the, uh, MDC and
had it consciously duck and, uh, get as close, my face is
close as I could to the bottom of the hatch.
In order to, uh, get past the, uh, get the OBS past the MDC
and get on out.
TV and darkest relation, uh, work fine.
I could hang on with the right hand on the, uh,
hatch, uh, the great big, uh, D handle on the hatch.
And, uh, with the TV pull on the left hand,
and it worked out real fine to just, uh, stick it in there
and line it up with the mark and, uh, make sure it was, uh,
locked in or clamped in.
And then, uh, climbed on up the pole to turn the TV on,
or turn the, uh, deck on.
And it was, you couldn't see the light.
It couldn't see the light on the thing, but you could feel the
camera running once you turn it on.
You could just touch it.
You could feel it, feel the vibrating a little bit.
The, uh, lunar sound or cassette, uh, retrieval.
Um, I think, uh, there should be on the onboard, uh,
or on the air ground takes.
As I was describing, I was going to go on with no problems.
The pan camera cassettes were next.
No problem on the pan camera cassettes on the pan camera.
It's obviously a bigger mass, and it's, it's, uh, quite apparent
when you try to move, move that big mass around that it is heavier
to waste more than, uh, the other things.
It's easier to move, but it just takes a little more effort to get
it started, and you know that if you ever get a start in one
direction, it's going to keep on going.
You have to stop it.
So I just, uh, moved everything real slow, tried to keep
it down to control.
Mapping camera cassette had the same, uh, problem I had in the,
uh, in a symbi, uh, C squared S squared, getting the, uh,
thermal cover off.
It's stuck underneath the mapping camera.
These are all timber, uh, door.
But, uh, there's no real problem.
You know, at the feet of the shoes, just give it a big jerk
and then it finally came off.
Same bay inspection.
Uh, that's all covered in the onboard, uh,
I mean, the air ground takes.
TV and Docker removal, uh, again, was real simple.
It just had to squeeze the, uh, deliver.
And TV came out, and it was easy to hang on with one hand.
And maneuver the, uh, uh, TV around and point it
toward the moon, because I didn't have to worry about
trying to get into the sun.
And I tried to, again, hang on with one hand and point the
off TV around toward the earth.
It was there.
It was one maybe 10 or 15 degrees, probably 15 degrees
from the sun.
And I tried to be a little more accurate on the same.
When I did that, then I lost, kind of effectively
really lost control of my body position,
because I was trying to, to, uh, I think maneuver the
camera.
And I just, you need both hands to maintain your body control
again.
So rather than try to flesh the camera through the sun or
something like that, I gave up and tried to point the camera
out there.
Comparing EVA, uh, was loud and clear for me throughout the,
uh, throughout the EVA.
There was a lot of background noise that hissing, uh,
of the airflow.
And I'm sure that was probably kind of over the, uh, the box
circuit circuit.
But, uh, don't know if anyone had, didn't appear to me
that anyone had any trouble on the ground.
I think one of the big, uh, advantage here,
uh, on pity that one thing we did, because it was bothering
in the first week, I turned here more box sensitivity down about
two notches.
And apparently that really improved the conform.
It was a question.
I, I, I've got a question from the ground.
I don't know if it did, if it made a difference in output,
but I got the impression that it did help.
I'm into the cabin was excellent.
I never had any trouble understanding the idea of seeing
it in a background, but we did.
Yeah.
I thought it sounded much better.
And I remembered other flights sounding.
Mm-hmm.
On the air ground.
Well, our sampling made more noise than that.
I guess he's on all work.
Uh, it was clear.
Clear.
Yeah.
Uh, ingress, uh, seemed to me like it was easier than
he dressed.
Yeah.
For some reason, uh, hash closing was, uh, harder than I anticipated.
And I guess maybe this is the, uh, the same reason is that I must have
been exhausting into the cabin all the time.
And just a lot.
The hash would come close to within about an inch of closing on the
outer edge.
And then it took an effort to pull the hash close so that you
can activate the, uh, the latching handle so that you can
over, get the, uh, the lashes over the center.
Of course, once you got the first stroke on the latching,
you have it, uh, got the, uh, the latches over center.
Then it's, uh, really just a couple more pranks on the, uh,
on the hatch, uh, closing.
Can repress, uh, it was nominal.
I mean, uh, and my content here was selling the, uh, all I did was
working in the hatch area.
And, uh, I want to emphasize, I mean, what everybody's always
said is that you do your best work when you take things slow and
easy and just let yourself, uh, move yourself in small increments
to where you want to go.
You can turn and dip and break yourself out.
And I think it's also useful for any cabin,
patch or, or port operations, uh, have somebody else available
to, uh, push you out on your tether as far as you want to go.
And I'll put you in at just easy operation,
getting this engagement.
Okay.
Uh, but, uh, what, uh, what the tire with the scrups and
everything available there.
There was never any feeling that I couldn't have a way to control
my body position.
And sometimes it took a few seconds to get it where I wanted
it.
The one thing, invariably, every time I went back inside,
I was had this 90 degree disorientation feeling for a few
seconds until I got the perspective of the cabin again and said,
okay, that's right.
And I get back in and then I go back outside and I come back
in again.
And once again, it seems as if the cabin had rotated 90 degrees
to my perspective.
And, uh, it just, something, there's no problem.
It's just a change of perspective for some reason.
I, I, I experience several times.
Uh, I guess the biggest problem working in that angle for me,
Sunango, our attitude was, uh, I, I had the sun because
you had the sun in your eyes.
Once we come in, sort of made it hard to look and detail
and see what you were doing.
You were clear-endaged.
You were there.
I could see every major operator doing it, but if I
could specifically see details of the sun.
Oh, I, one, one point I wanted to make, uh, also wasn't,
I had no awareness whatsoever.
Gotta head in and build it for on the back.
It was, I never got to feeling that the umbilical was
tugging on me, restricting my movements.
Or many think I didn't even know it was there.
And did you observe at any time that the umbilical ever
did tugging around the umbilical?
It was, uh, it was easy to tend.
And I frankly don't remember a single time when I
had the, uh, clear it.
There may have been one.
Some of you have a big impression at one time.
I asked you to hold up.
Or maybe I didn't see anything.
I just moved it away from the handhold or something,
but the umbilical was, uh, was very,
didn't tend to snake around.
And it was, you seem to have everything you needed on it.
I didn't even know it was there.
I guess that's the point I was making is it really,
that being tied to the umbilical does not restrict your
movement or, or give you a feeling that it's,
it, it is restricting your movement at all.
Soot doffing in storage, don't think we've already discussed that.
Uh, this is continuing on the EVA part of it,
but, uh, I don't know.
This is just a different section here.
Soot doffing in storage.
We've already mentioned the Soot doffing in storage.
Uh, the light flash, uh, phenomena.
We, uh, drilled for bountiful for an hour and, uh,
never saw a light flash.
That was the final second.
The second route.
I don't know where that, and, uh, transferred.
You're doing resting exercise,
but I don't know.
We're going to add to the light flash,
so it'll be that the next,
a bad evening, I guess it was,
I did see them again.
Probably asleep.
It's okay.
So, I did do.
Right.
So there was just that period,
apparently during the actual experiment,
if there's somebody sitting there with this.
I think we've discussed the eating, uh, resting there.
Actually, I was covered already.
Kevin atmosphere.
Uh, the one thing, uh,
that I don't think we've, we've ever mentioned yet.
And I think should be noted is that we,
uh, never really utilized the waste storage vent
to get rid of any orders out of that waste storage compartment.
And if you, when you kind of drifted over in that area,
it was always a ground that you were in that area.
Do you have a real close to what I thought?
I don't know.
I guess maybe I did when you opened a door.
That's when you really know.
It's Kevin, generally.
Turned over the atmosphere in pretty good style.
It got saturated sometimes with, uh,
with gas and it took, uh,
a few minutes,
once they'd sourced that gas was, uh,
uh, with plug up the, uh,
the cabin did a good job of recirculating cleaning out there.
I think it did.
I think real good.
Flight plan updates were super.
The flight plan was excellent.
Anyway, I'll do a minimum.
And we really didn't change any part of the entire flight,
except a few days and times and, uh,
what happened here in the attitudes.
Uh, but other than that, it was really in a minimum.
Let's see the entry preparations.
Read it again after EVA and continue off through the next day.
And, uh, we had very little final storage to do on entry morning.
Just those things that we had to leave on stowed until we got, uh,
got out of our sleep restraints.
So we basically just had to cut the big bags down on a one and two
and seven and eight.
And, uh, final entry preparations went by the,
by the checklist.
And, uh, if anything, we stayed about five minutes ahead.
Uh, throughout the entire checklist,
including, uh, separation and activation of the, uh,
uh, command module RCS, and, uh,
picked up five minutes up the course right at O5G,
which came on time.
Communications, I thought, uh,
were very good through up here at a time.
We were through a riot the last couple of minutes,
part of our RRT.
And, uh, I understand how the ground hurt everything we said
right on through blackout into blackout.
And, uh, and it said we came out of blackout.
They still had a riot.
And they could read us.
Uh, and we could have read them, but they never canceled anything.
Well, that was a little crap.
Yeah.
You know, I'm not a taker.
You know, I can't think of anything.
Well, on the quarter or six,
so we got, uh, horizon.
Right?
Yeah.
Without any, well,
with, with problem of looking.
But, uh,
but we had a lesson on the order within seconds of the actual time.
There were all within seconds, and, you know,
I, in this, in this CMS, I'd always look for the 2G,
when the quarter of that would go out, though.
I didn't even notice it.
I didn't know what.
So I must have been, I was either watching something else.
Uh, I must have been checking the,
the EMS or the...